rien n'arrête le sky rugby dans le
championnat de promotion d'honneur les
saint quentinois leader et grand favori
pour la montée en fin de saison ont
continué leur marche en avant ce
dimanche 19 février contre triel les
mureaux le troisième du championnat
après avoir remporté facilement la
première période 20 5 le sky a maîtrisé
la seconde partie du match pour valider
sa victoire à 27 à 10 h aux grosses
satisfactions par le score non seulement
on marque quatre points au classement
mais trial qui est un concurrent direct
en mai et 0 donc grosse satisfaction
autre point positif les saint-quentinois
ont su répondre au défi physique imposé
par leurs adversaires du jour
un match très engagé des deux côtés qui
s'est soldée par trois cartons jaunes
pour chaque équipe
triel les mureaux a également écopé d'un
carton rouge
trial une équipe qui truquent beaucoup
qui à la limite de la règle en
permanence donc du coup c'est difficile
difficile à gérer pour larbi difficile à
gérer pour nos joueurs donc à l'arrivée
son regard ils ont pris plus de cartons
que nous donc on a gagné le match de
l'indiscipliné faut savoir répondre dans
le jeu des fois on sort un peu du jeu à
savoir se concentrer sur le ballon et y
rester
cette victoire permet au sky rugby de
compter dix points d'avancé sur le
second avec seulement une défaite
concédée depuis septembre une marche
suffisamment importante pour commencer à
préparer la saison prochaine ça avoue
qu'à trois ans ça fait trois ans qu'on
construit trois ans qui répond bien
trois ans qui qui se construit dans les
corps dans les têtes et l'idée c'est
d'aider à présent être prêt si on
remplit notre objectif pour le
championnat honneur qu un championnat
très rugueux comme on a vu aujourd'hui
prochain match le dimanche 26 février
sur le terrain de chilly mazarin le
deuxième du classement l'occasion de
plier définitivement le championnat